i think that it's definitely racialized
when we are talking about um
megan specifically and her proximity to
blackness because her mum
is a black woman yes megan identifies as
biracial but her mom is a black woman
and
the press are very much aware of this
the institution is very much
aware of this and we know that the
stereotype um
that's often afforded or inflicted upon
black women is the angry black woman
stereotype black women are seen as
aggressive
and intimidating and so that same
narrative is being used for her in this
case i don't know megan personally
however i know that trope very
personally i know it viscerally and
that's what i see at play here yeah and
gina do you go along with that and it's
that story is told isn't it in some of
the language that is being used it goes
way back some of the language that's
been used
about megan right when they hooked up
for the first time
absolutely i mean you cannot deny the
racial
uh over terms of the the reporting the
the headline
almost straight out of content she's
from nowhere near compton and that did
not that is just
harks to hood and ghetto and gangs and
stuff like that
these kind of things that they were
putting into people's minds talking
about how it
was exotic dna um you know the the
difference in the way that she was
depicting the press
was when when kate middleton eats an
avocado it's wonderful it's full of
owners
and and then when she eats an avocado oh
it's linked to human rights abuses
and the whole bullying thing whether
these accusations are true or not
these accusations were from three years
ago and it's only now they've suddenly
decided
to to release that information and do an
investigation
it's a it's a transparent and pathetic
attempt to smear her before this oprah
winfrey interview comes out because
they're scared
of what she's gonna say the way that
she's been covered has just been
ridiculous the angry black woman trope
is so obvious
oh she's up at 6 00 a.m sending out
emails
it's awful it's bullying and yet if
she'd been waking up at 11 what would
they have said then oh well we don't say
they're lazy but
what 11 a.m she could not win in this
situation
but gina just to stay with you on that i
mean people will say well
the language was never overtly racist
you touched on some of the phrases that
were used
used in the press um unroyal was another
one that comes to mind
you know what do you read into that well
unroyal
why because she's come from a broken
family did did prince harry not also
come from a broken family why is he not
being called
unroyal is underhand it's passive
aggressive
but you know exactly what they're saying
the the talking about her dna
the the talking about her mother's dark
skin and her dreadlocks that
you know it's it was so obvious it's
obvious to anybody who's willing to
look and collect i mean people say
in the united kingdom well you know
we're sorry they felt they they had to
leave and and what is this about
about racism a lot of people i've heard
say well we didn't even know that megan
was black we're not racist
the issue with um the issue with the uk
is that i think that we
are dealing with a deep malaise that has
festered
it it's at the very core of us as like
our society
our laws are built upon them the very
institutions and systems that we know
um wholeheartedly are built upon and
racism the very great
in britain is the number of great
atrocities that were committed
and all in the name of empire so really
when we talk about for instance megan
being um a bully quote-unquote then um
i feel like who is the true bully you
know
for us to have the monarchy to me it's a
representation
of the colonization that's taken place
that we've renamed just the commonwealth
that
is a legacy of bullying bullying pretty
much most of the world
so if megan were in fact to be a bully
i don't know her but if she were in fact
to have been a bully would she not
just be exacting the very narrative that
has upheld the monarchy as we've known
it throughout the centuries
i don't know but i understand that the
way that the
media have been and talking about her
that can affect somebody's mental health
we know that she recently had a
pregnancy loss and now she's expecting
another child surely we shouldn't be so
aggressive towards her but that doesn't
seem to matter
her you know her livelihood her safety
her protection
doesn't seem to matter to the british
public so when we say
oh well we're not a racist country and
why i didn't even know she was black
well no we
we know her mom's black we saw her mum
at the royal wedding
and i think that it's those narratives
it's the kind of systemic gaslighting
that we're seeing nationwide that's
allowing for this to happen
okay i'm glad to say we're joined uh now
well sorry gina
gina please come in on that but we've
got another guest joining us in a moment
but but gina please and what i was
saying is
that this whole notion we didn't know
she was black the language that has been
used eamonn holmes on
british tv called her uppity now if you
know that the connotations of that word
the word apathy is
a word used by white people to to talk
about black people who are acting above
their station
in being able to speak properly and
being able to read and stuff and for him
to use such a word
is laughably racist and for him to then
say that he didn't know what it meant
if you're going to use a word on
national tv that you don't you don't
know what it means or what its true
meaning is
then maybe you should look it up before
you use it so don't tell me that there
are no or we didn't know we were racist
it's it's absolutely rubbish the problem
is everybody looks at american racism
and thinks oh yeah american racing so
into your face
british racing was just collect more
cleverly done americans bought black
people from africa and put them in
plantations
in america it was very much in your face
the brits and europeans hid it they did
it on caribbean islands
they hid their dirty deeds but it
doesn't mean it didn't happen
and it still had and this is why we have
a problem with discussing racism now
because they've spent so many hundreds
of years hiding it so well
okay and look we've been joined i'm glad
to say
bye shola moss shogba mimu very good to
talk to you
sherlock come on into this conversation
and you'll have heard what we've been
discussing some of the
the tropes uh particularly racial tropes
surrounding meghan markle
give me your views on that and add in
here there's also a
a rather traditional sexist one as well
isn't there of uh the gullible man being
led astray by the powerful woman
let me just say first of all that my
sisters gina and kelechi are
absolutely on point and let me just add
to what they said
the level of idiocity from the
capacity particularly those of the
british media
has reached the levels of utter in you
know ridiculousness
i mean when we think about the fact that
megan is being treated worse
think about it worse than somebody that
has actually committed a crime
and the way they deny that race has
something to do with it is
truly ridiculous people have to
understand that
black and biracial people black heritage
race always plays an issue because
racism intersects with other forms of
inequality that they experience
okay we don't need to write it on our
forehead those who go well show me an
example what's wrong with you are you
blind can't you see
are you illiterate can't you read what
is it that is
it's right in your face that you refuse
to deconstruct i mean do we need to send
you back to school i'm afraid that even
if we do send you back to school
if it was one of the top like pizzas and
already you still come back the same
the point here is major marker right now
is being used as an example of what
happens to you
if you don't fit the mold and the three
black women you see on the screen right
now we're examples of
get off her back because we will not
tolerate this nonsense
when you do that to megan marco of
course you're doing it to pass as well
the reason why
you know that the british press is
getting such backlash is because
we've seen this before not just the
major but to us
we know what it looks like the writing
is on the wall
and when you whether you have all these
comments around prince harry can i just
say prince harry
is the husband to megan that prince
charles never wants to diana and that's
saying something
that is saying something right there
this is a man who's understood
that history can repeat itself and it's
like you know what
like nigerians would say prevention is
better than cure
as far as i'm concerned i'm actually
tired
and i think a lot of people are really
sick and tired of the toxicity
and i never really talked about the
royal family but right now
i have to say the firm is seriously
ticking me off
i know for a fact there is no way
question palace
or so-called royal aids can sneeze
without royal approval
so how it happens then you see that days
before this big old opera
interview all of a sudden they're
regurgitating repackaging
glimpse of bullying that happened a
couple of years ago
and all of a sudden bucky and pilot okay
why did you investigate it in 2018 what
happened then
what happened actually going through a
thorough investigation
what people need to understand is that
when it comes to black people especially
black women
accusing us of being a bully is just as
bad
as saying that we are guilty we are
guilty unto proven innocent
and enough is enough with that okay
listen i've got a last
question for you all i think i suspect
it it will be and it's
following on from what you've all been
saying and the point shoal is making
there
about the royal family let's flip this
round and gina do you think they've
therefore missed a real chance here
to genuinely signal that they're
modernizing they're changing
they're listening and and in some sense
atoning for past sins
yeah they missed a massive opportunity
they got a black woman in the royal
family
they had their all they had to do was
stand up for her that's all they needed
to do
is to stand up for her against his
onslaught
by the press and it was an onslaught you
know the fact that
a bbc presenter felt like it was okay to
post a picture of a chimpanzee
when her baby was born if they'd only
stood up there
then they would have they would have won
the hearts and minds of
everybody and they they chose not to and
now they're choosing to attack her
days before this oh it's pathetic it's
transparent and collection you talked
earlier about um
the empire the role obviously the the
british royal family
in that uh same question to you then
about a a missed opportunity here for
for a modernizing modernization of the
royal family
yeah i mean what are we modernizing uh
we're modernizing um
rape pillage theft and then displaying
it in the
british museum what were we really
modernizing i think that
i'm i'm actually glad the way that all
of this is playing out i obviously
wouldn't want that kind of
um the pain that megan has had to endure
surely not however
i do believe that we are seeing a
crumbling of the monarchy
and that needs to happen if we're
talking about a true equitable
society that is a just for all
that is fair for all then surely we
can't have the hierarchy that we
currently have
in terms of the monarchy so they are
you know they put themselves on notice
really by the way that they've treated
megan which goes to show that the very
pervasive nature
of the racism that has upheld the
monarchy for so many centuries
um it's not something that you can just
wish away it's not something that you
can marry away
they're going to have to reckon with
that all of us as a nation will have to
reckon with that
well uh i said before the interview
started that you'd say your mind uh we
were not
disappointed uh kelechi show lagina
very good to see you all please come
back